[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à lévis et le pétrole elle était là pour
moi ce serait oui alors je vais jamais
vous abandonnez la boîte
alors je vous raconte la boîte à lui pas
le tout homme a les couleurs je suis
sensible alors tu m'étonne un peu sur la
gauche
alors si ça va sauver haïti mme moi si
ça vous bassam ballon là il ya une boîte
vous allez rire mais bizarre qu'est ce
qu'il ya dans cette boîte
rien rien rien ouest et est - rien
l'intérieur y'a rien à l'intérieur ne
laissait un gars c'est joli comme cadeau
à ne mettre rien sauf devrait devant la
caméra
je suis là parce que moi je veux faire
une incantation il ya tellement de shola
pas ici que j'aimerais bien faire venir
avec comme ça les hommes bcg est
maintenant de maintenant on y va
oui allez ben ouais ouais bah oui de
boules rouges à sortir de là
[Rires]
mon rêve c'est un vrai show lapin sur l
eau
mais non c'est vrai ce qui à l'intérieur
j'ai gardé la mer
je pense
[Applaudissements]
c'est magnifique
j'avais alors
[Applaudissements]
alors vous devez leur mettre dans la
boîte à cesser votre lapin je crois
qu'il m'a fait caca dans les vallées
c'est pas très grave est que du bonheur
vient bernard goutta plus quand même
c'est un grand classique de la magie on
imagine bien
ah oui sortir le lapin d'une boîte ou
d'un chapeau effectivement et puis quand
on aime les animaux on adore ça et il
est très c'est vraiment on la paye ça va
être obligé vu naître et je les ai
perdus de vue
107 ans
[Rires]